شكرا للزميل طالب كنعان اهلا بكم الى سعه
اخباريه مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات المشهد
السوداني نبداها بالعناوين
رغم الهدنه الاخيره دوي انفجارات وتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في محيط القصر الجمهوري
بالخرطوم
المبعوث الاممي للسودان يعلنوا قبول الجيش
والدعم السريع ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض
ويرجح استضافه السعوديه لها
عمليات الاجلاء من بورتسودان تستمر هربا
من المواجهات
وتسعه واربعون رحله اجلاء جويه تصل الى
جده
في نشرتنا ايضا
تظاهرات في مدن فرنسيه ضد اصلاح نظام
التقاعد والنقابات تتوقع مشاركه مليون
ونصف فرنسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم رغم الهدنه المعلنه في السودان
الا ان مراسل العربيه افاد بوقوع اشتباكات
متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع تركزت في
محيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تصاعدت اعمده
الدخان في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش قال
ان الدعم السريع فقد نصف قدراته العسكريه
منذ بدء المواجهات مؤكدا استقرار الموقف
العملياتي ومع استمرار خرق الهدنات
المعلنه لم يجد الاف السودانيين الا
النزوح سبيلا للهرب من الاقتدال الدائر
وفي اليوم السابع عشر شهد السودان هدوءا
حذرا رغم بعض الخروقات التي وقعت في
الساعات الماضيه حيث شهد محيط القصر
الرئاسي اطلاق نار باسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه
واشتباكات متقطعه وقصيره في شارع المطار
بحسب مراسل العربيه على ضفه المقابله
للقصر الجمهوري في منطقه حله حمد بخرطوم
بحري سمع في ساعات الصباح اطلاق نار ودوي
مضادات ارضيه للدعم السريع اما في اقصى
الجنوب الغربي من الخرطوم حلقت مقاتلات
الجيش فوق منطقه جبل اولياء والى الشمال
من بحر ايضا سمع اطلاق نار بالاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه تحديدا في ضاحيه شامبات
في هذه الاثناء ومع تجدد الاشتباكات رغم
الهدنه المعلنه خلت الشوارع الرئيسيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من الماره في
حين شهدت المحل التجاريه التي فتحت
ابوابها جزئيا ولساعات محدوده ازدحاما
سعيا للحصول على المواد الغذائيه وبعض
المستلزمات الحيويه خاصه في ظل ازمه
ارتفاع الاسعار بشكل مضطرد واظهرت صور
خاصه بالعربيه خلو الشوارع الرئيسيه في
الخرطوم من الحركه المعتاده مع استمرار
الاشتباكات المتقطعه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحه في عمار ابو
شيبه عمار مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
ماذا لديك من معلومات حول تجدد الاشتباكات
مره اخرى حول محيط القصر الجمهوري في
الخرطوم وهل من اشتباكات في مناطق اخرى في
العاصمه
نعم يعني تجدد الاشتباكات كان هذا من قبل
اكثر من ساعتين في هذه اللحظات هنالك
هدوءا نسبيا وحذرا جدا في هذه المناطق لم
نستمع لاصوات اشتباكات ربما الان المعركه
على ارض الواقع فيها هدوء نسبي
محاوله من الطرفين ربما للهدوء واعاده
الصفوف من جديد بحسب طبيعه المعارك ما بين
الكر والفرع لم نستمع في هذه اللحظات
والدقائق الماضيه الاشتباكات في المنطقه
ولكن هنالك معلومات كثيره جدا ترد الينا
فيما جرى في مدينه بحري من القصف
للطيران الحربي على عدد من المواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع ايضا الجيش كان قد نشر فيديو
قبل دقائق لسيطره الجيش على موقع او معسكر
سلاح الاشاره بمدينه ام درمان وسمع في تلك
المناطق عدد من
الاشتباكات وذوي المدافع في منطقه وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم كانت هنالك اشتباكات قبل
ربما نصف ساعه من الان في المنطقه المحيطه
بالمطار والمنطقه المحيطه بقياده الجيش
وايضا كذلك القصر الرئاسي وهذه اماكن
رئيسيه تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريع
وايضا كذلك في عدد من المناطق التي تشكل
الجانب الغربي من ولايه الخرطوم وحتى في
الجانب الشرقي ما يعني ان مساحه
الاشتباكات في هذا اليوم ربما تمددت وربما
تقلصت نوعا ما بطبيعه المعارك التي جرت
منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى الان وما فيها من
تفاصيل دقيقه جدا خاصه وان سلاح الجو
دائما ما يدخل مساندا لعمليات التمشيط
ويستطيع من خلال القدره الفائقه ان يحقق
اهدافا على المعركه فيما يخص القوات
المتمركزه على الارض من ثم تاتي قوات
المشاه لعمليات التمشيط ولكن بالجانب
الثاني تتحدث قوات الدعم السريع بانها ما
زالت موجوده في تلك المواقع وما زالت ذلك
الهجوم من خلال المضادات الارضيه ومن خلال
كثير جدا من عمليات الارتكازات والكمائنه
التي تم نصبها في تلك المناطق قوات الدعم
السريع بالحديث ايضا عنها كانت قد اعلنت
قبل قليل انها تعرضت عمار الى
الى الى الى قصف ربما في احياء سكنيه من
قبل طيران الجيش وقالت بانه لا يزال يحلق
في سماء الخرطوم الى اي مدى هذا دقيق
نعم كان هنالك تحليق للطيران الحربي يعني
من خلال الاعمده المتصاعده للدخان والتي
نشاهدها من الاتجاه الشمالي من مدينه بحري
وتلك المنطقه كما هو معلوم بان قوات الدعم
السريع تتحصن فيها وتنتشر فيها بكثافه في
المناطق القديمه من البلده وايضا كذلك في
المناطق الشرقيه تتمركز تلك القوات دائما
ما يتم الحديث بان الطيران الحربي قد قصف
ربما اهدافا سكنيه ومدنيه ولكن بطبيعه
المعركه القوات تتمركز داخل الاحياء وعدد
من الشوارع الرئيسيه وايضا كذلك عمليه
التمشيط تقوم في تلك المناطق هذا ربما ادى
الى كثير جدا من وقوع الضحايا في تلك
المناطق بسبب الاشتباك المتبادل وبسبب
ايضا عمليات الرد ما بين الطرفين عمليات
الجو بحسب كثير من التحليلات وبحسب كثير
ما نشر الجيش من معلومات يشير الى ان
العمليات الجويه لديه فايقه الدقه وتستطيع
ان تنفذ اهدافا من غير ان الاهداف الاخرى
قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث بان هذه الطلاعات
الجويه لا تقصف قوات الدعم السريع بل هي
تقصف احياء سكنيه وتقصف المدنيين في مناطق
سكنيهم بشكل واضح على الارض هنالك الكثير
جدا ربما من عدم الحركه كثيره جدا انعدمت
الحركه بشكل واضح في عدد كثير جدا من
شوارع الخرطوم وهذا يدل على ان عمليات
الاشتباك داخل الاحياء او في الطرق
الرئيسيه ما يمنع حركه المواطنين وما يمنع
كذلك جدا من الوصول الى عدد كبير جدا من
المستشفيات او المراكز الصحيه او حتى
التزود بالحاجيات الغذائيه والحاجات
اليوميه التي يعتاد عليها المواطن في
حياته اليوميه رغم الندره ورغم الشحف كثير
جدا من السلاح وربما تاكيد لكلامك ايضا
عمار هذه
طبعا الكاميرا الخاصه للعربيه المباشره من
الخرطوم وهي تنقل لنا الصوره حيه ومباشره
من العاصمه السودانيه وكما ذكرت يعني هناك
ربما ان
في الحركه بشوارع العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم مع دخول الهدنه السادسه حيز
التنفيذ قبل منذ طبعا 12 ليلا
البارحه السؤال الان يعني اذا كان الجيش
يحلق ويقصف مواقع ربما للدعم السريع
والجيش كان في وقت سابق قد اعلن بانه ربما
سيطر او اغلب مواقع ومراكز الدعم السريع
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم فاين تتحسن
او تتمدرس هذه القوات في الخرطوم ان كان
من معلومه عمار
نعم يعني الدعم السريع منذ فتره طويله له
عدد من المعسكرات داخل ولايه الخرطوم وحتى
في اطراف العاصمه وهذه المعسكرات هي
محاذيه لعدد من الاحياء السكانيه سواء في
منطقه جبرا او في منطقه والتي تقع في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم او في منطقه بحري في
معسكر المظلات والذي يقع في الجانب الغربي
او في منطقه شرق النيل او في منطقه شرق
وغرب مدينه ام درمان وعدد من المعسكرات
الطرفيه ايضا التي كان يتشارك فيها الجيش
مع قوات الدعم السريع وهذه المعسكرات هي
داخل هذه العاصمه وهذه المناطق ذات
الكثافه السكانيه بيان الجيش حمل خطا
انشاء قوات الدعم السريع للنظام البائد
والنظام السابق واعتبر ان هذا خطا
استراتيجيا ومن ضمن هذا الخطا الاستراتيجي
بحسب هذه الاشاره هو ان هذه المعسكرات
تكمن داخل هذه المجمعات السكانيه باعتبار
ان الجيش
والتكويناته فرقه العسكريه تكن نوعا ما
بعيده عن التجمعات السكانيه ولكن لطبيعه
تصميم وقدرات قوات الدعم السريع كانت
لديها مرونه وسهوله الحركه ربما ايضا بحسب
كثير من المحللين العسكريين تتجه هذه
الخطوه لانها لابد لها ان تكون متمركزه
داخل مناطق قريبه ما تشكل دعما واسنادا
سريعا وهذا ربما نستطلعه من اسم القوات
باعتبارها قوات دعم سريعه بشكل الاسناد
ودعم لقوات الشعب واضح اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من
الخرطوم انضمي الينا الصحفي عمار بوشيبه
هذا وشاهدت عدد من المخابز شرق العاصمه
الخرطوم عوده تدريجيه للعمل واستقله
الموارد وانعدام الامن
الناس بامانه تعبت في ناس تعبت كثير في
اطفال
فقدت حياته في اسره الان الحمد لله بدات
تفتح
والامور ماشيه خير ونتفائن ربنا يصلح
الحال وضع سيء وضيع سيل للغايه
سي سي سي سي سي سي لابعد الحدود
اظهرت صوره خاصه بالعربيه تصاعد اعمده
الدخان في المنطقه الصناعيه بالخرطوم بحري
مع استمرار سماع اصوات انفجارات واشتباكات
متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
قبل ذلك اكد بيان للجيش ان الاوضاع مستقره
في جميع ولايات السودان وبحسب البيان حشدت
قوات الدعم السريع اكثر من 65 الف عنصر
والفين مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان
يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف مضيفا انه تم احباط عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه قادمه لقوات الدعم السريع
من اتجاه الغربي الى الخرطوم
هذا وتواصل وحدات من الجيش السوداني اجراء
عمليات تمشيط في منطقه الخرطوم بحري بينما
تستمر الاشتباكات المتقطعه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
في المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع على
قطاتي فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى
القنص في مبنى القصر الجمهوري وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وقالت قوه الدعم السريع انها
تسيطر تماما على القصر الجمهوري ومحيطه في
الخرطوم بالاضافه الى مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في ام درمان كما اكد احد قاده
الدعم السريع ان سيطرتهم على القصر
الجمهوري تاتي ضمن مساعي الدعم السريع
للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب
المسلح بان هذا العمل الذي زجت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع في داخل
القصر وفي كل ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي
منه الحفاظ على سلطه الشعب
قال المبعوث الاممي للسودان فولكر بيريتس
ان طرفي النزاع وفقاع على ارسال مندوبين
للتفاوض بين الجانبين واضاف بريت في حديث
لوكاله السوشيتي ان المحادثات ستعقد على
الارجح في السعوديه المبعوث الاممي قال ان
التفاوض سيركز في المقام الاول على ترسيخ
وقف اطلاق النار بشكل مستمر وموثوق مع وضع
فكره انشاء اليه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار
تضم مراقبين سودانيين واجانب
وفي تصريحات اخرى حول الاوضاع الانسانيه
قال بريتشن العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه
الخاصه بالامم المتحده تم نهبها مشيرا الى
ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا
العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه التي كانت
موجوده في المخازن تم نهبها كل المخازن
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومفوضيه الشؤون
اللاجئين في دارفور مركبات وكالات الاغاثه
تعرضت للسرقه مكاتبي ايضا في دارفور تعرضت
للسرقه لم يتم احترام وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل كان الالتزام جزئيا وفي مواقع
دون الاخرى
وينضم الينا من باريس المتحدث باسم تجمع
المهنيين السودانيين في الخارج الدكتور
امين ناصر مكي دكتور امين مرحبا بك معي في
هذه الساعه اريد ان اسال اولا عن موقفكم
في تجمع المهنيين السودانيين منذ بدايه
هذه الازمه الى اليوم هل تغير فيه شيء هل
تغيرت المعادله بالنسبه لكم دكتور امين
شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه الرحمه والمغفره
والمجد والخلود لكل شهداء السودان وعاجل
الشفاء للجرحى والعوده للمفقودين
موقفنا في تجمع المهنيين السودانيين من
اليوم الاول
لسنا في الحياد ولكن ضد هذه الحرب العبثيه
التي قلنا انها ليس للشعب السوداني فيها
ناقه ولا بعير هذه الحرب التي زج بالجيش
والقوات الدعم السريع فيها بها ولكن للاسف
الخسائر معظمها من المدنيين والضحايا
معظمهم من المدنيين نحن نتحدث عن اوضاع
انسانيه صعبه جدا في السودان
نتحدث عن الاف
النازحين
والذين خرجوا الى
ولايات ومدن اكثر امنا داخل السودان وهناك
ايضا من نزحوا الى
او بلدان حدوديه اخرى هذا الوضع الانساني
الانساني الكارثي الذي يواجهه السودانيون
نامل ان ينتهي قريبا نحن لسنا محايدون نحن
ضد هذه الحرب جمله وتفصيله
نسعى في هذه الاثناء مع بقيه القوى
السياسيه لحث كل الاطراف المتقاتله سواء
في القوات المسلحه او في قوات الدعم
السريع بالالتزام بالهدنه
ووقف دائم لاطلاق النار هناك مباحثات
جاريه
لان تكون هناك كما ذكر ضيفك قبل قليل
تستضاف السعوديه او في جده مباحثات لوقف
اطلاق النار وتم تسميه ممثلين عن القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع لان هذا في
الاول والاخير في مصلحه الشعب السوداني
الان نتحدث عن التفاوض ونتحدث عن ابداء
حسن النوايا لوقف اطلاق النار ولكن
اطلاق النار هل تواصلتم انتم الان في تجمع
المهنيين السودانيين هل تواصلتم مع طرفي
النزاع لبحث اي تسويه ممكنه ونقل الصوره
ايضا او او موقف الاحزاب السياسيه
السودانيه بالنسبه لطرفي النزاع البرهان
وحمد
الاجسام المهنيه المنخرطه داخل تجمع تحت
التجمع المهنيين السودانيين هي جزء من
الاجسام والقوه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي كلنا مع قوى السياسيه والقوه
الموقعه للاتفاق الايطالي
سعينا منذ اللحظه الاولى
سعينا من قبل لعدم اشتعال هذه الحرب ولكن
هناك من نفخوا
من نافخي الكير وحماله الحطب من نفخ في
هذه الحرب واشعلها منذ البدايه من انصار
نظام المخلوع وكلنا شاهدنا ذلك ولكن بعد
ان اشتعلت هذه الحرب حرسنا تماما
لاننا حريصون على الشعب السوداني وحريصون
على
اهلنا في السودان ان تتوقف هذه الحرب تم
التواصل مع الجميع لوقف والالتزام بالهدنه
وبفضل هذه الجهود بحمد الله
تمديد الهدنه ل 72 ساعه ولكن نامل ان
يلتزم الطرفين بالهدنه لاننا الان في هذه
الاثناء ونحن نتحدث الان هناك قصف على
المستشفيات هناك قصف على المدنيين نحن ضد
اتخاذ المدنيين كضروع بشريه ونحن ضد
استهداف المستشفيات وقصفها والقصف
العشوائي الذي يروح ضحايا المدنيين
وكي الامين العام للامم المتحده سيتوجه
الى السودان قريبا جدا لبحث هذه الازمه
والتي ربما حذر منها او وصفها ايضا بانها
تتفاقم ويعني الازمه ربما
هي في في موقف صعب وتتجه للاسوء ما الذي
تتمنونه على هذه الزياره فيما يخص العمليه
السياسيه التي توقفت في السودان
نتمنى من المجتمع الدولي ان ياخذ القضيه
السودانيه على محمل الجد نحن نتحدث الان
عن هدنه انسانيه وهناك تم مشكورين في
منظمات الصليب الاحمر ايصال
معدات الطبيه
للمستشفيات في السودان وهناك طائره اخرى
ستاتي قريبا نتمنى ان يتم فتح الممرات
الانسانيه نتمنى الضغط على الجمرات
المتحاربين في السودان على ايقاف دائم
لاطلاق النار وان يعودوا الى طاوله
التفاوض
لنتحدث
بحل كل مشاكل السودان يمكن ان تحل
بدون
اصوات الرصاص والمدفعيه وقصف الطائرات لان
هذه هي البنيه التحتيه للسودان السودان هو
المتضرر الاكبر والشعب السوداني هو الخاسر
الوحيد من هذه المعركه نتمنى تتم جهود
والضغوط من المجتمع الدولي
لقاده هذه الجيوش المتحاربه ان
يتحكموا الى صوت العقل لان في النهايه
المتضرر هو السودان ونامل ان تنتج هذه
المفاوضات الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على انضمامك الي في هذه
الساعه من باريس المتحدث باسم التجمع
المهنيين السودانيين في الخارج الدكتور
امين ناصر مكي
ومع استمرار المواجهات يواجه الكثير من
السودانيين مصاعب حقيقيه في ممارسه حياتهم
اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال الدائر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع فيما يواجه عمال الاجره
اليوميه معاناه مع استمرار الاشتباكات حيث
اختفت فرص العمل بسبب الحرب
فتره الطول الحرب بنيه شغل لكن معاناته
والله بامانه كده يعني حكايه ظرف صعب جدا
جدا العمل متوقف
ذات الحروب
بعد العيد لحد هنا ما في شيء
المواصلات عشان تجي السوق ده وترجع السوق
من القريب ده بالنسبه لمحل انا دليته 3000
وبفضل اكون قاعد في بيتي
وفي ام درمان قرر الالاف من السودانيين
النزوح من مناطقهم هربا من الاقتتال
الدائر فيما يتجه كثيرون الى بورتسودان من
خلال حافلات لنقل الركابات التكلفتها اغلى
من المعتاد بسبب نقص الوقود يقول الاهالي
في ام درمان ان العائلات تتجه الى مواقف
الحافلات سيرا على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر
وسائل للنقل مع استمرار الاشتباكات
المسلحه الرغم ان الخرطوم للولايات فبرده
يعني الحاجه صعبه شديد يعني اول كلمه ماجد
خاش الشعبي لقيت دفار بعشره
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر فما بالك يعني
باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباصات اسعاره حتكون كيف
نوجهها الولايات حاليا يعني الباصات كلها
بتمشي بورسودان 12 13 مليار لو بنفسجي
وفي متابعه لعمليات الاجلاء يتوافد المئات
من الرعايه الى ميناء بورتسودان ضمن
عمليات الاجلاء المستمره هربا من الاقتتال
الدائر
نحن الان هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق
السودان سناخذ جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا
المركز الرئيسي الذي يضم مئات من الاسر
الذي التي بدات في التوافد الى مدينه
بورسودان نبدا بالجهد الشعبي الذي يوازي
هذه الاعداد الكثيفه الان هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ممثله في غرفه الطوارئ عامله على
توفير هذا المستشفى المؤقت وهذه الغرفه
المؤقته للطوارئ للتعامل مع عدد من
الحالات التي قد ترد الى هذه المنطقه
حالات لسوريين وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم
الخدمات في هذا المركز الذي انشئ قبل
يومين في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما
ذكرنا عددا من السوريين وعدد من اليمنيين
وايضا اضيفت اليهم نسبه اخرى من المقيمين
السودانيين الذين يحاولون ايضا عبر هذا
المركز ان يغ ادروا هذه المنصه هنا في شرق
السودان الى عدد من الدول عبر من بورسودان
السودان عايش في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
[موسيقى]
يعني بجد السودان في حاله تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا الميناء وبره وعلى
الكورنيش الناس بتنوم في الارض ارامل
اطفال مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين
هنا في مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير
يوفرون اصلا مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في
الارض ويعني اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي
كلنا جايين من اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتين من
الخرطوم
وفي متابعه لجهود السعوديه بشان عمليات
الاجلاء فهدى مراسل العربيه بوصول سفينه
حربيه امريكيه تقل 318 اشخاص من سته عشره
جنسيه قادمه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي واضاف مراسل العربيه ان جد
استقبلت 26 سفينه اجلاء قادمه من السودان
حتى الان بالاضافه الى 49 رحله اجلاء جويه
من بورت سودان وصلت الى جده تقل اكثر من
2000 شخص كما ستغادر طائره عسكريه هنديه
من جده الى السودان لاجلاء 140 شخصا
بين مدينه بورتسودان يلتحق بنا مراسل
العربيه نزار البقلاوه نزار مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه نزار الى اين وصلت عمليات
الاجلاء من ميناء السودان حتى اللحظه
العمليات مستمره منذ الحادي والعشرين من
شهر ابريل المنصرم عبر هذا الميناء من
خلفي مباشره من بورسودان ومستمره كذلك عبر
مطار بورت سودان الدولي منذ الثالث
والعشرين
تحل حديثنا عن اكثر من اربعين رحله جويه
اقلعت من عدد من المطارات في المنطقه
والاقليم وحطت هنا في مدينه بورسودان في
المطار الرئيس واقلعت مباشره لتنقل
الرعايه بواقع 6 الى 8 رحلات في اليوم هذه
اعداد مقدره تفوق 9000 عبر مطار بورسودان
الدولي حتى الان احصت الجهات الرسميه او
اللجنه المعنيه بعمليه الاجلاء اكثر من 22
رحله بحريه لقطع وسفن بحريه وصلت خلال
الساعات الماضيه والايام الماضيه الى
ميناء بورتسودان واتجهت صوب مدينه جده
والى عدد من الموانئ على البحر الابيض
المتوسط وايضا على البحر الاحمر هذه
العمليه مستمره اللجان المعنيه بعمليه
الاجلاء سواء كان على طريق الميناء البحري
هنا في بورسودان او عبر المطار تمضي خطتها
وفق الجدول الموضوع من قبل اللجنه العليا
لعمليه التفويج وعمليه المغادره من
الخرطوم وصولا الى مدينه
هنالك ايضا لجان امنيه ولجان فرعيه تعمل
ايضا على تامين هذه العمليه عمليه الاجلاء
هنالك ايضا جهد رسمي ممثلا في حكومه ولايه
البحر الاحمر تعمل ايضا على تنظيم هذه
العمليه بالتنسيق مع اللجنه الامنيه
وبالتنسيق كذلك مع هيئه الموانئ البحريه
التي ايضا تشرف على تنسيق وترتيب وصول
القطع البحريه ووصول القطعه الحربيه للسفن
التي تصل تباعا الى هنا في مدينه بورسودان
نزار يعني وانت معي الان على الهواء نتابع
هذا الخبر العاجل لاسفل الشاشه
لمنسق طبعا الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه يقول بان هناك شحنه ادويه من
الصحه العالميه تنتظر اذنا لدخول السودان
هنا اريد ان اسال عن ان كان هناك من اي
مساعدات قد وصلت عبر البحر عبر ميناء
بورتسودان للدخول الى السودان او هناك طلب
لاذنات دخول هذه الشحنات ان كان هناك من
معلومات متوفره لديك نزار
نعمل اذونات متواصله يعني بدا بعد ان بدات
هذه المواجهات والاشتباكات المسلحه خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين كان الصليب الاحمر
الدولي وكانت منظمه الغذاء العالمي وكانت
عديد منظمات الغوث الدوليه كانت قد وجهت
برقيات ونداءات ورسائل للسلطات هنا في
السودان بضروره ان تتدخل بصوره عاجله
للتعاطي مع الازمه التي تحدث في السودان
سواء كانت ازمه وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
او الغذائيه في بعض من المناطق تحديدا في
اقليم دارفور والذين توجهوا صوب الاراضي
التجاريه على حدود جاد الشرقيه
بالفعل وصلت مساعدات خلال الساعات الماضيه
والمناشدات ايضا مستمره من مختلف ايضا
الواجهات والقطاعات هنا في الشرق السودان
وفي عدد من مدن السودان وتحديدا في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم التي اطلقت
فيها ايضا منظمات واجهات صح نداءات
وبرقيات بضروره ان يتم المساعده وان يتم
الاسهام في
الدفع العمل خاصه في القطاع الصحي الذي
يشهد تدهورا ملحوظا عدد من المستشفيات
الان خرجت من الخدمه بالتالي هذه
المساعدات التي تصل وستصل الى السودان
بامكانها ان تخفف من وطئه ما يعانيه
المدنيون والسودانيون وعدد من الاجانب في
عدد من المدن التي شهدت اشتباكات المسلحه
خلال الايام الماضيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من مدينه
بورسودا مراسل العربيه نزار البقداوي ومنه
الى ومنه الى جده الى هاني اصفيان مراسل
العربيه اني مرحبا بك معي الى اين وصلت
العمليات عمليات الاجلاء في جده التي وصلت
الى جده من بورتسودان حتى هذه اللحظه سواء
كان عبر البحر ام كان عبر الجوف في قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه والملك فيصل
نعم نايف اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا من هنا من قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه بالقطاع الغربي في تحديدا في
مدينه جده غرب السعوديه طبعا نحن نتحدث
قبل لحظات كانت وصلت الطائره او الرحله
رقم 50 والتي نفذت هنا او تنفذ في قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه في مدينه جده هذه
الطائره التي تحمل على متنها 135 من رعايا
الهند وهي طائره عسكريه هنديه طبعا الى
جانب ايضا الجسر الجوي المستمر ما زالت
عمليات الاجلاء في الجسر الجوي مستمره
سواء من قبل الطائرات العسكريه التي
تنفذها القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه او
كذلك عبر الطائرات العسكريه التي تنفذها
دول عده ايضا عمليات المغادره هؤلاء
الرعايه من هذه القاعده الى بلدانهم ايضا
لم
توقعنا ان تنخفض وتيره الرحلات ولكن بدات
الرحلات الان في ازدياد فمثلا الرعايه
الهند بحسب حديث القنصل الهندي يوم امس ان
هناك او قرابه
ومئتين شخص ما زالوا عالقين وايضا هناك
بعض الرايه لم يستطيعوا التواصل معهم ايضا
لا يختلف الامر كثيرا بالنسبه لرعايه
القنصليات الاخرى بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه
وكذلك ايضا الامريكيه الذي تحدثوا اليوم
عند اجلائهم عبر السفينه الامريكيه التي
وصلت ميناء جده الاسلامي فان هناك بعض
العالقين الذين لم يستطيعوا التواصل مع
سفراتهم او حتى سفراتهم لم يستطيعوا
التواصل معهم اذا نحن نتحدث عن الان مشكله
في او عمليه في عمليه العالقين وعدم
استطاعه السفرات او بعض السفارات
الاوروبيه بالتواصل مع رعاياها
المساله ايضا هنا هناك اعداد كبيره ممن
الان يبحثون عن عمليات اللجوء او ايضا
عمليات الاجلاء عمليات متواصله سواء في
الجسر الجوي وايضا لو نذهب هناك في الجسر
البحري فحتى الان نفذت 26 رحله بحريه من
بورت سودان الى جده سواء عبر القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والتي اخذت نصيب
ثلاثه عشر السفينه يقابلها ايضا 13 سفينه
من الفرقاطات البحريه او القطاع البحريه
العسكريه للدول الاجنبيه وكذلك السفن
التجاريه
الاجنبيه نتحدث اليوم عن اجمالي ما وصل
الى السعوديه من عمليات او من ركاب الذين
كانوا على متن الرحلات الجويه او كذلك
البحريه تجاوزوا
7,500 شخص حتى هذه اللحظه في انتظار ايضا
وصول قطع بحريه قادمه خلال الفترات او
الساعات القادمه فمثلا هناك سفينه تابعه
للقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه سوف تصل
خلال الساعه المقبله عبر او سوف تصل الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا في مدينه
جده وايضا سوف تكون هناك رحلات جويه خلال
هذا المساء عبر الجسد الجوي من هذه
القاعده قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وسوف
يستمر الحال ايضا في ساعات متاخره من
الليل ولكن عبر ايضا القطاع البحريه
الاجنبيه التي سوف تكون او تقف على رصيف
ميناء جده الاسلامي كيف يتم التعامل هاني
مع رعايه الدول الذين وصلوا مثلا الى جده
ولم يتم مثلا التعرف عليهم من قبل سفراتهم
او القنصليات او ليس لديهم حتى ربما علم
بوصولهم الى جده سواء عبر
الرحلات البحريه او الجويه ايضا كذلك
او هذه المساله في السودان فقط
اعدادهم كبيره وكثيره نعم وهي مساله نعم
بشكل سريع يتم استخراج التصاريح وكذلك
وثائق سريعه بعد ان يتم التاكد من
قنصلياتهم والتعرفه على قنصرياتهم هؤلاء
الرعاياهم كذلك يتم منحهم تاشيرات سريعه
طارئه حتى تمكنهم من الدخول الى الاراضي
السعوديه ومغادرتها او مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم لانهم في النهايه سوف تكون
مغادرتهم اما عن قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه هنا او كذلك عبر مطر الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي حقيقه هناك تنسيق مستمر بين
الخارجيه السعوديه وايضا بين سفرات
القنصليات هؤلاء البلدان وكذلك ايضا في
عمليه الاستجابه السريعه من خلال اللجان
الموجوده سواء في الخارجيه السعوديه او
كذلك في القطاعات الامنيه والعسكريه
الاخرى نتحدث اليوم عن اكثر من 30 جهه هي
تعمل من اجل هؤلاء الرايه وعمليه اجلائهم
بسلام وامان اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جده
مراسله العربيه هاني صبيان على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
وعلى الحدود المصريه السودانيه افاد مراسل
العربيه بان التقديرات تشير الى دخول نحو
15 الف سوداني الى مصر عبر المنافذ البريه
ياتي ذلك فيما يصل السودانيون الذين قرروا
الفرار من النزاع عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري
لتكون مدينه ابو سنبل اولى محطات
استقبالهم هل المدينه حرصوا على تقديم
كافه انواع المساعدات للنازحين نتابع
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من معبر قسط البري الوجوه المرهقه من عناء
الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع استقبال
اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود المصريه
الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين ما تيسر
من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي السودان قبل
استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه اسوان احنا طبعا
لازم نقف جنب اشقائنا السودانيين في
الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا عملنا المبادره
دي مع شباب القريه عندنا وحسين انه احنا
اهل البلد الخدمه اللي قدموها لنا ما
حسستنينه لسه ما زلنا في السودان يعني بعض
القادمين لا يملكون الاموال اللازمه
لاستكمال الرحله احدى المجموعات النازحه
توجهت الى وسط المدينه لتفاجا برد فعل
الاهالي الذين قاموا بجمع المساعدات
المطلوبه
والله انا يعني سم ده ما نزل مو سمبل وانا
بقينا الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم
والله كل خير يعني احنا نقوتهم فوق راسنا
مع بعض وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونه للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه ففضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سم
بل حلات
هم لمست
قبليه للمبيت في بيوتهم للراحه من وعفاء
السفر الطويل سكان ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما
بان السودان يمثل لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا
فقط ولكن انسانيا ايضا كلمات وشعارات
برهنه الاحداث على مدى مصداقيتها احمد
عثمان العربيه من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه
اسوان
حنا تقريبا حوالي
345 العدد كبير جوا الميناء وبره وعلى
الكورنيش الناس تكون في الارض ارامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني
اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين
اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتيه من الخرطوم
ومع استمرار المعارك في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم تزداد الاوضاع المعيشيه سوءا يوما
بعد اخر هذه قصه عائله اطرت الى ترك
منزلها بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء والعيش
على وجبه طعام واحده في اليوم
من ناف
ذه غرق بوهبه شوارع مدينه غاب عنها الامن
والسلام منذ اسابيع خرجت مع عائلتها
الصغيره من منزلهم في الخرطوم بعد انقطاع
الماء والكهرباء جراء القتال
لتستاجر العائله غرفه فوق سطح مبنى في
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه لعلها تجد فيها بعض
الامان وابسط اساسيات الحياه
[موسيقى]
لكن صوت ضربات المدفعيه والطيران والرصاص
كان مصاحبا لهم كيف لا وهذا هو الحال في
الخرطوم كلها منذ اندلاع الصراع اصوات انا
كل يوم بسمعها
مرعبه شديد يعني بخاف على ناس البيت بخاف
على نفسي
بتمتمات ودعوات تصلي والده هبه من اجل
ابنائها ومن اجل وطن غادره الامن
والاستقرار وعمت فيه الفوضى ولا يعرف ما
ينتظره
انسان ربنا يعني بالعافيه والناس تبقى
كلها طيبه الوضع يرجع لوضع الطبيعي ونرجع
بيوتنا لانه طولنا بالجنه من بيوتنا
الكهرباء قاطعه لحد
الدعامه قاعدين قدام بيتنا ما دايرين
يزحوا ما راضيين ان نصلح العمود بتاع
الكهرباء طبعا الكهرباء ما في مويه ما في
عشان كذا انا زحمه مرقنا من بيوتنا
قلق العائله الصغيره وخوفها ليس من وابل
القذائف والرصاص فحسب بل تخشى ايضا من
انقطاع الامدادات الغذائيه فلجات الى حياه
الكفاف
غذائيه
كل الدكاكين مقفوله والموجوده باسعار
غاليه شديد بنحاول ناكل اكل قدره حد
الكفاف يعني بناكل وجبه عشان تكفينا باقي
المواد الموجوده لليوم اللي بعدي
قصه من بين الاف القصص لاسر تكافح في
الخرطوم وتبحث عن ابسط حقوقها حق العيش في
سلم وسفينه وسلام وربنا يصلح الحال ويرجع
حال السودان احسن من اول بالكثير ملوك
الشيخ العربي
اتهم الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني بتحويل
مستشفى السلاح الطبي بام درمان الى منصه
للقصف المدفعي واشار في بيان له ان القصف
المدفعي العشوائي من مستشفى السلاح الطبي
ادى لمقتل واصابه كوادر طبيه بحسب تاكيدات
الدعم السريع واضاف ايضا ان طيران الجيش
لا يزال يحلق في سماء الخرطوم ويقصف احياء
سكنيه
قال المبعوث الاممي الى السودان فولكربيت
سن العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه الخاصه
بالامم المتحده تم نهبها مشيرا الى ان
الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا
العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه التي كانت
موجوده في المخازن تم نهبها كل المخازن
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومفوضيه الشؤون
اللاجئين في دارفور مركبات وكالات الاغاثه
تعرضت للسرقه مكاتبي ايضا في دارفور تعرضت
للسرقه لم يتم احترام وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل كان الالتزام جزئيا وفي مواقع
دون الاخرى
هذا ويواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغ عددهم
حوالي 45 مليون نسمه ازمه جوع متصاعده ما
دفع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي لوصف الوضع
الانساني في البلاد بالكارثي
معاناه على معاناه تجثم على قلوب
السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محلهم التجاريه
او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق السودان يشكو
ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات سابقه متداخله
الوضع الانساني كارثي او كما وصفه الامين
العام للامم المتحده بلغ نقطه الانهيار
السودان اسره على السلطه في السودان لا
يعرض مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه
يضيء فتيلا يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود
ويسبب معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه
الى الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه 15 مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي ومع اندلاع
الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه عشره
تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب اغلاق
ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور التحدي
الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كثيره هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري
نحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه فهذا الاستقبال
[موسيقى]
الان وقفه
ومتابعه لابرز الاخبار الدوليه حيث خرج
فرنسيون للتظاهر في فرنسا لاحياء عيد
العمال ولمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون وتوقعت النقابات الفرنسيه
نزول ما يصل الى مليون ونصف المليون الى
الشوارع وقال الامين العام للاتحاد
الديمقراطي الفرنسي للعمل انهم يتوقعون
مشاركه مئات الالاف من المتظاهرين موضحا
ان النقابات اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف
انحاء البلاد لاحياء عيد الاول من مايو من
جهتها تتوقع السلطات نزول نحو 650 الف
متظاهر من ضمنهم ما بين 80 الى 100 الف في
باريس وحدها كما اكدت ان اثني عشر الف
عنصر من الشرطه سينتشرون لضمان الامن
وهذه صور مباشره امامنا مشاهدينا من بدايه
هذه التظاهرات لاحياء عيد العمال في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وعدد من المدن
الفرنسيه ايضا كذلك نشاهد الان وربما ايضا
كذلك الشرطه تتعامل مع المتظاهرين وتحاول
تفريق المتظاهرين كما نشاهد الان على شاشه
العربيه وايضا ربما اطلاق بعض
القنابل المسيله للدموع كذلك ايضا لتفريق
هذه التظاهرات التي خرجت احتجاجا على نظام
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون وافق عليه طبعا
المجلس الدستوري الفرنسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في جنوب فرنسا تجمع المتظاهرون في تولوز
في مسيره
بمناسبه عيد العمل او عيد العمال واحتجاجا
على اصلاح نظام التقاعد الحكومي الذي اقره
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
[موسيقى]
من باريس يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه فادي
الدهوك فادي مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
فادي هل بدات هذه المظاهرات حتى اللحظه في
باريس ام لا يزال المتظاهرون يجتمعون عند
نقاط الاجتماع او الالتقاء ايضا في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس اليك
اهلا نايف التظاهر الفارسي بدات والموكب
الان يسير
بالمسار المخصص له سابتعد قليلا عن
الكاميرا لترى
الالاف من الفرنسيين او ربما عشرات الالاف
الان في الشوارع هم يسيرون في هذه
التظاهره بمناسبه عيد العمال وهذا اليوم
هو اهم يوم في السنه بالنسبه للفرنسيين
وخصوصا العمال لانه يجمع اعداد غفيره
تاريخيا للتظاهر لاحياء هذه المناسبه لكن
اليوم عيد العمال ياتي على وقع ازمه
سياسيه
واجتماعيه تعيشها فرنسا نتيجه رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما لذلك هو يوم خاص جدا
خصوصا وان هناك كما ذكرت هذه الازمه اليوم
كان من اللافت ايضا نايف ان هناك مشاركه
من عدد كبير من الاشخاص من جنسيات او من
دول مختلفه هناك مشاركه
من الولايات المتحده من اسبانيا من سويسرا
من تركيا ومن كولومبيا كلهم اتوا الى
باريس لاحياء هذه المناسبه لان العاصمه
باريس تعتبر احدى رموز هذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه في يوم العمال وكما ذكرته اهم
يوم في السنه بالنسبه للعمال وبالنسبه
للنقبات ايضا النقابات تتوقع ان تكون
اعداد المشاركين نحو مليون ونصف المليون
شخص اليوم في عموم انحاء البلاد هناك
تظاهرات انتهت بالفعل في عدد كبير من
المناطق الفرنسيه لكن التظاهر الفارسيه
وهي الاهم اليوم بدات قبل ساعه تقريبا وهي
تسير نحو وجهتها الاخيره نحو ساحه الامه
في وسط العاصمه باريس ليس لدينا حتى الان
اعداد المشاركين لكن كما ترون على الشاشه
الاعداد كبيره جدا وهي ضخمه ومن اجل
مواجهه احتمال حدوث مواجهات او اعمال شغب
الشرطه حشدت 12 الف شرطيا في عموم انحاء
البلاد 5000 منهم للعاصمه وحدها هل حدثت
اي اشتباكات بالفعل بين قوات الشرطه ايضا
التي قالت بانها ستؤمن هذه المظاهرات او
رصدت اي شيء لان الصور التي كنا نراها قبل
قليل على شاشه العربيه تظهر اعداد كبيره
من قوات الشرطه وربما ايضا الرشق بقنابل
مسيله للدموع كما تابع
[موسيقى]
نعم المواجهات بدات مبكرا بشكل مفاجئ في
التظاهر الفارسيه لكن هي مواجهات محدوده
حتى الان لا تستمر او هي
ثم يعود وضع الى الهدوء هناك اشتباكات
طبعا حصلت ايضا في مدن اخرى في ليون في
مارسيليا وفي نانط هناك ايضا حالات اعتقال
والشرطه استخدمت الغاز المسيل الدموع
بكثافه في تلك المناطق وايضا هنا في
العاصمه باريس هناك ايضا كما ترون على
الشاشه المتظاهرون يقومون باشعال الحرائق
في بعض المناطق التي يسيرون فيها طبعا حتى
الان الوضع
الهادئ نسبيا برغم وجود اشتباكات متفرقه
في زوايا مختلفه الموكب كبير جدا وضخم
لذلك هناك مجموعات تنتشر في معظم الشوارع
هناك ايضا عناصر كثيره للشرطه التي حذرت
كذلك من وجود ما بين الف الى 2000 شخص من
عناصر اليسار المتطرف الذين يحاولون
افتعال هذه الاشتباكات والمشاكل مع الشرطه
طبعا هذه الاشتباكات التي تحدث هي تنجم
عندما يق هؤلاء المتظاهرون باستهداف احد
البنوك او شركات التامين هل يعني انتصرت
مطالبات المتظاهرين باسقاط نظام او اصلاح
النظام التقاعدي فقط فادي ام هناك مطالب
اخرى لهم
المطالب الرئيسيه هي ضد رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما بعدما قام المجلس الدستوري
باقراره وبالتالي وقع عليه الرئيس الفرنسي
وايضا هناك هتافات ضد الرئيس الفرنسي
يطالبون باستقالته وباستقاله الحكومه طبعا
هذا اليوم هو يوم مهم جدا للحركه
الاحتجاجيه والنقابات التي حشدت صفوفها
خلال الفتره السابقه للضغط على الحكومه من
اجل منع تمرير رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
وفشلت في ذلك لذلك اليوم هذه المناسبه هي
مهمه جدا وهي اختبار لمدى زخم التظاهرات
وصمودها في وجه الحكومه لكي تجبرها على
التراجع عن هذا القانون كذلك هناك مبادره
لطرح استفتاء حول هذا القانون سوف يعطي
المجلس الدستوري رايه فيها في يوم الثالث
من هذا الشهر كذلك اشكرك شكر جزيل على هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل الصوره التي نقلتها
لنا من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس فادي الده
المراسل العربيه شكرا لك
اذا في اخبارنا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها وجهت ضربه لمنشات المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الاوكراني ومصانع انتاج الذخائر
والمعدات العسكريه واضاف المتحدث باسم
الوزاره الكسندر كوناشينكو فان كل المواقع
المخطط استهدافها تم ضربها فجر اليوم وشرى
ايضا الى ان القوات الهجوميه الروسيه حققت
مزيد من التقدم غربا باخمه
طلب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
من اليابان تزويد بلاده بوسائل للحرب
الالكترونيه للتصدي للطائرات المسيره
واعرب عن تفهمه لموقف اليابان التي لا
تورد الاجهزه والتكنولوجيا العسكريه سوى
للدول التي تطور معها تلك الوسائل بسبب
قيود دستوريه كما اعلن الوزير عن خطط كييف
لشن هجوم مضاد واسع النطاق دون تحديد موعد
معين لبدء العمليه
بقي الملك تشارلز ولي للعهد 70 عاما وهي
اطول فتره في تاريخ الملكيه البريطانيه
الممتده لاكثر من اربعه قرون وطيله هذه
الفتره اقترن اسمه بزواج القرن مع الاميره
ديانا وعلاقته المتوتره معها ايضا والتي
انتهت بطلاقهما قبيل وفاتها
[موسيقى]
الثالث ملك بريطانيا واربعه عشره دوله
اخرى في الكومنواف بعد ان انتظر اكثر من
70 عاما لاستلام العرش اثر وفاه والدته
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه في سبتمبر الماضي
وهي اطول فتره من قبل واريث العرش في
التاريخ البريطاني
تشارلز هو الاسم الكامل عند ولادته في قصر
عام
1948 وهو الابن البكر للملك الراحله
وزوجها الامير فيليب اصبح وليا للعهد منذ
كان عمره ثلاث سنوات على عكس اسلافه تلقى
الملك تشارلز تعليمه في المدارس العامه
وكان اول افراد الاسره الملكيه من يحصل
على شهاده جامعيه في عام
بلقب امير وينز في مراسم قلدته فيها
والدته الملكه اليزابيث فاجا امراء
على خطى والده استكمل الملك تشارلز خدمته
العسكريه واصبح الطيارا في سلاح الجو
الملكي كما التحق بدوره في الكليه البحريه
الملكيه قادته الى مهمه على متن مدمرات
وفرقطات
في عام
1981 تزوج تشارلز اول مره من الليد دايان
سبنسر الارستوقراطيه والمعلمه في روضه
اطفال في حفل تاريخي وصف بزفاف القرن
العشرين انجب الاميرين ويليام هاري لكن
قصه الحب تحولت بعد سنوات الى كابوس
وانتهت بطلاق الزوجين بسبب علاقه تشارز
الغراميه لفتره طويله مع كميلا باركا بولز
ما ادى الى تراجع شعبيته حينها في العام
2005 عقد تشارز وكاميلا قرانهما في حفل
زفاف مدني متواضع في وينزر
[موسيقى]
بارائه القويه حول مجموعه من القضايا بما
فيها السياسيه على عكس الحياد لدى العائله
الملكيه الى جانب اهتماماته بالهندسه
المعماريه والزراعه العضويه وحمايه البيئه
ارائه تسببت في تعرض الانتقادات من قبل
البعض لكن اخرين معجبون بتفهمه والتزامه
ويرونه شخصا مخلصا قضى حياته في الدفاع عن
القضايا التي يؤمن بها وغالبا ما يوصف
بانه ملك فيلسوف بسبب فضوله الفكري
واهتمامه بمجموعه من القضايا
[موسيقى]
الملك تشارلز الثالث في سباق للترك بصمته
الخاصه في تاريخ الملكيه البريطانيه خصوصا
وانها لن تكون طويله على غرار المده التي
قضتها والدته في الحكم بالنظر الى عمره
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
اعتقلت شرطه التركيه مجموعه من المتظاهرين
في ميدان تقسيم الشهير في اسطنبول حيث
جاءت تلك الاعتقالات لمجموعه كبيره من
المتظاهرين في عيد العمال اقبل اسبوعين من
الانتخابات العامه في البلاد
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه تغطيتنا
لاخبار السوداني مستمره مع الزميل طالب
كنعان على راس الساعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات